et pourquoi tu t'appelles Doc Gynéco
parce que
je suis l'homme que toutes les femmes
elles ont en commun
alors comment ça va
on a vu des flics en venant là ils sont
cachés non mais sérieux il y a trois
flics qui sont cachés derrière la
station-service on dirait qu'il joue au
cow-boy au sein bien je te jure il y en
a un qui regarde comme ça non mais
vraiment ils sont comme ça ils se plante
tu vois pour regarder comme d'habitude
[Applaudissements]
toi moi
je sais pas parce qu'on dirait vraiment
les Pieds Nickelés là derrière ils sont
planqués et tout
[Musique]
et pourquoi tu t'appelles
je suis l'homme que toutes les femmes
elles ont en commun
c'est-à-dire
madame Mitterrand
toutes les femmes
c'est pour ça
c'est pas un peu dur à porter non en ce
moment ouais mais c'est bon
quoi tu t'es marié presque arrête tes
conneries
grâce à un secret c'est une amie
d'enfance
et tu fais pas partie de ministère
Hammer toi à fond un fondant si tu sais
que j'ai un procès à cause des ministère
à mort entrevue
on va passer vers là-bas il y a des
copains à moi
il y avait une histoire tu sais mais les
déclarations de ministère Hammer dans
l'entrevue et
on est poursuivi par le ministère
publicitaire
à main pour avoir interviewé ministère
je m'en occupe de ce journal mais je
peux te dire que c'était chaud et les
mecs ils ont gueulé
vraiment dur quoi les syndicats de
frites et tout ça carrément
c'est violent quand même il y a un
troisième album ministère
j'arrive
c'est un petit spliff non
je sais pas c'est un quartier très cool
on connaît tout le monde ici les filles
qui travaillent sur le boulevard
c'est cool regarde les gens avec leur
enfant tout ça c'est pas ce qu'ils font
là
ils sont speed tout seul ils sont il
s'énerve même
il faut le toit allumage
ça va tu as eu du souci toi avec les
avec les flics
non non jamais
à part avec ministère Hammer comme toi
ouais
on est dans le même cas finalement
c'est ça
moi pas grand chose
ils sont toujours là mais stomie
Stomy stomie il risque une grosse amende
et peut-être
non rien d'autre
ouais en ce moment on me dit que ça va
bien ça marche bien mais les mecs des
ministère Hammer ils t'en veulent pas un
peu d'être passé dans un genre plus non
c'est pas variété c'est un esprit de
ministère Hammer mais toujours ministère
Hammer c'est ça la force de ministère
Hammer c'est Doc Gynéco comme ça
stomie qui peut te faire des jeux flirt
avec le meurtre ou des sacrifices de
poulet
pas si
en solo on donne tous un truc différent
mais c'est toujours l'esprit c'est le
plus cool de la bande toi
peut-être que j'ai moins souffert
celle qui passe tout le temps à la radio
viens voir le docteur
comme beaucoup de filles tu rêves d'être
Brenda d'avoir ton Dylan et d'insulter
ton papa mais moi j'ai 200 aspects et 50
unités je ne fais que serrer et me la
raconter j'ai bluffé des non en pleine
prière j'insulte mon père et j'invoque
Lucifer j'ai fourré mon doigt dans ton
intimité écarte les cuisses si tu veux
apprécier ne viens pas chercher le plus
grand chien du quartier j'ai déjà piqué
toutes les chiennes enragées remonte ton
froc quand tu sors du studio pantin pour
promo M6 moi passer je suis sûr et je
suis foncé leur a part en couille et je
lui prête mes boules moi j'ai le manche
et le ministère roule même à l'envers si
tu ne sais pas le faire mes soldats sont
en guerre et le doc en est fiers si tu
veux pécho viens je te vends des mots
mon grossiste et Virgin achète en kilos
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu